bonjour c'est jamel debbouze pour brut
[Musique]
tout le monde se calme on est là
maintenant tant que comédien comment se
prépare commencé mais dont le nom la
peau d'un suricates
c'est très simple c'est sain régime
alimentaire déjà pour commencer qui ce
qui constitué essentiellement d'insectes
de l'arbre des fourmis et puis en dehors
du régime
ouais il ya des exercices particuliers à
faire surtout au niveau du coup tu vois
et un client truc organique obligé pas
eu de mal à camper ce personnage là
parce qu'on le connaît tous simon aux
lentilles on les bat lyon ça va voir
dis-moi ce que c'est ça n'est pas allé
on c'est un oiseau poilus on dirait un
lion non parce que soit regardée plus
près pardon ça lyon chariot sauvetage à
la rébellion il est tout petit
s'agrandit ces bêtes là on peut le
garder on peut le garder s'te plaît
allez bien sûr qu'on peut garder on va
l'appeler michel c'est une bande rythmo
qui passe au fur et à mesure des images
donc effectivement on a le temps de se
familiariser un peu avec le texte mais
je vous avoue qu'au début la première
fois j'ai même pas regardé le texte
c'est tellement subjugué par les images
que je comprenais pas ce que je voyais
[Musique]
ap
hakuna matata
dans le studio de doublage est ce que
vous êtes tout seul est ce que vous avez
joué avec allemand a un rôle à jouer on
a demandé à être ensemble généralement
les seuls dans des cabines derrière une
barre ça c'est sombre et puis et puis il
ya réalisateur qui nous dit plus vite
moins vite plus fort moins fort qui
règle le ton et le rythme là on la
demande à être ensemble parce que
d'abord on s'aime beaucoup parce que le
duo on avait le sentiment qu'il fallait
que ce soit organique et j'ai même
demandé à être sur son dos pendant tout
le tout tout tout l'enregistrement
battant qui m'ont fait porter par coumba
pendant tout le film fallait respecter
la partition et non oui ça apporte
quelque chose d'être ensemble on déjà
onze touches et il ya un truc aurait
j'ai pas au rythme à l'oreille kékem
nick est différente
il ya une énergie différente quand on
est ensemble et comment ce que les
depuis longtemps avec alban jeu que les
juges aient connu était comme ça il vise
un mètre cube et ça fait des années
qu'on se connaît on n'a eu aucun mal à
camper ces personnes âgées et je veux ce
duo avoir allions faire autant son camp
ça n'est peut-être pas une mauvaise idée
c'est incroyable de voir de se retrouver
dans un disney tu en as été bercée par
les disney faut dire ce qui est on fait
entrer dans toutes les chaumières la
disney c'est que quelque chose qui nous
avons pratiquement éduquer d'une
certaine manière et et de l'eca voit un
personnage disney c'est comme rentrer au
louvre tu vois une certaine manière
c'était impression de rentrer dans la
postérité que ça va rester longtemps
après toi c'est une chance et c'est un
kiff
[Applaudissements]
j ai skié la première fois que j'ai vu
le roi lion c'est mon copain hassan
québec à payer une entrée on est en
train 10 par la sortie de secours
au cinéma le grenier à sel désolé je
referai plus jamais et je conseille à
personne de le faire mais c'était un
film qui était tellement incroyable
c'est un tel événement comme je veux pas
rater ce à quoi et ça que tu cherches ça
coûtait cher les places de signer à
l'époque ça coûte toujours cher
d'ailleurs la place de signaler c'est
pas normal
c'était une sensation en train dans
cette salle en plus le fait d'avoir
resquiller ce encore plus goûtu 10 lms
comme ça le film j'avais pris dans la
tronche
un moment unique des images
époustouflantes une histoire
shakespearienne des dialogues des
personnages désopilants
ça veut dire très drôle non j'ai une
sensation assez unique
c'est que c'est un film marquant y en a
quelques-uns comme ça des films qui vous
restent dans la tête dont celui là